the widest variety of wild Pokemon out
of any area in the games and it also
changes the Pokemon you can encounter
depending on the weather conditions
where you go in the time of day so no
machito machi Orton idle no more
potential Minonk I'm opening autogyro
cottony animus a total emitter that I
Krakatoa camera Oh June Lucas Scott Oh
radical you know day for in your demo
which the IPO military solo tornado
Kokomo service photo meticulous in the
wild air yet spans across multiple town
so your adventure will take you back to
this the wild area multiple times and as
you can see on screen here you can
control the camera freely in this area
to better find hidden items that are
lying about and also see the pokémon
that are flying above in the sky well
yes and it looks like we are seeing
Pokemon out in the field here correct so
the most feared oh no Poe can go to the
door Oh steady on the Fantini are near
in the spirit of man so the snare is on
80204 go tarasana Shambhala encounter
beyond a tomar a became Montano
encounter tow a toaster domesticated big
furry macula Riddick you know Vanessa
domo arigato
Matt Cimber Pokemon there are no ni ikou
a pharisee Pokemon medicine I do some
random encounter no doc it expands
legitimate soon our civilian afternoon
so yeah we have the pokemon wandering
about the fields we call in kind of
symbol encounters you can see the
Pokemon before you actually encounter it
but at the same time you actually just
saw an exclamation mark pop up in the
tall grass there and that kind of
simplifies that it's a random encounter
so you don't know which Pokemon you're
going to encounter we wanted to have a
mixture of both types of encounters in
these games to also let play players
enjoy that excitement of you know not
knowing what they're going to encounter
yeah that's great it looks like we've
got a lot of different types of pokémon
that appear out here in the wild area as
well why do they do not complete the
journey ahead and you don't necessarily
know Airport in like video on your knee
anosmia hi so it's me it's all much
about or do they need to help I can say
no but including not a mistake my design
terracotta Bordeaux and I get 30 states
come out about over pretty much
then there's definitely a lot of Pokemon
to encounter and of course as you can
see here the battle system you know it's
the traditional turn-based battle where
you choose moves to defeat the wild
Pokemon before you can catch it or
battle against it's pretty sketchy
poking man became important topic Sega
after he became a single day and I
described a close you know taking the
hearing eaten optimized and you'll find
that they're you know Pokemon abilities
are back as well as the ability to give
them items to hold so there's definitely
a lot of depth to the battle system yeah
certainly I think fans are gonna look
forward to to the depth within that
battle system and they'll be able to
enjoy that both within the game as well
as in their one-on-one battles as well
so and then Matthew said family become
one for you I know yeah a Pokemon song
about to the back IDO enough to become a
player Madison High and post them all
thank you to people that you know so
this nexus in the Atty same study sono
Occupato resources master academy
resettlement asleep at I know commander
filter I carry on about Odin update you
must me yeah I definitely you can have
link battles with other players and of
course I think there's a lot of fans out
there that are looking forward to the
hand of this return of the really you
know in-depth or that deep battle
systems that we have to you know really
compete with each other at all mamita
mosquito more I know I missed a turn
this on the music typos no Pokemon
legitimacy they question your personal
team Koga cooperate amassed a facility
you carefully about forty title you can
do some other manner Pokemon Martin
Clunes ridiculously yeah you can see
it's actually raining right now where
we're wondering about and depending on
the weather condition the kind of
certain types of pokémon will appear
more frequently right now you will see
more water type Pokemon and maybe if it
was snowing you would see more ice type
Pokemon for exam
- Chico Valeria La Tengo Vikas Amodei
Rivini atrocity ayah mahkumat Sunday -
evil area in photos relate to personal
Tomas and the climb it's pretty dynamic
so if you come back a different day the
weather may be completely different so
we really think that players will have a
lot of fun coming back multiple times
and seeing the different Pokemon that
appear depending on the weather
conditions here so we're talking about
of the different encounters but it looks
like Terry can also whistle to attract
Pokemon and different Pokemon and have
different reactions to life does that my
income to system in the house goes high
so the one that took a cheaper way out
so it might unlock Ohana hope you guys
didn't hire one I'm a sociopath so
listeners know okay mom washing your
face discovery I told my prayer meter to
catalytic study definite or negative
okay more money mercy in a canister for
salt only the Pokemon photographs
commodification scheduled to be deported
a market ironic or video set that is a
Palestinian state my I don't know
Pokemon today I'll totally do nothing
yeah the whistle is kind of key to
encountering certain types of pokémon
for example if they're flying high above
you can't really you know encounter the
birdies which they have to attract their
attention by whistling at them but at
the same time be like you said they're
kind of different Pokemon react
differently than some might see you
whistle and run away for example or
others may be curious about you and
approach you
[Music]
Terri's doing a great job of battling
and capturing pokemon here in the wild
area just got my Metapod expanding the
party so I think for today's treehouse
live segment we're gonna explore this
part of the wild area as we kind of head
closer to one of the towns in the game
and that should give us a good sense of
this this one particular part of the
wild area but clearly there's a lot more
to the wild area than even what we're
showing here today mr. in Omaha kono
martini much cut through my attitude
Akio to the sofa in the promoter Hunter
he locked it on the bus all the while
daily any identity owner saw this in a
karate copayments leading me to show you
but anatomist a Motoko knee Akiba is a
theory for amount of a military status
in a civil no kimochi no hace poco poco
kuni tomita Catriona pokemons cometary
toe a little volcano monitoring Otto
- yeah this is just a small portion of
the wild area if you I mean if you
wanted to walk really far out there
there's lots of stuff to discover and
it's you know it's much wider than a lot
of available to discover for example
much stronger Pokemon that you may want
to go try and seek out the top of course
having me never ask for some of our
early death at least on the scale or
more came on your to us a prio meat
skeleton imitation hopefully memory
Massimo day or saga me neither reports
because it's close to the Korean
encounters report emotive human
yeah we were actually just I think Terry
was showing the crouching down motion
where you can kind of get into tall
grass and quietly approach some of the
more perhaps timid Pokemon otherwise
they might run away from you
we talked about how when the weather
changes that specific Pokemon like up
here more often so like right now it's
hailing so there's a different variety
doesn't he might kill gossip didn't know
they took the chi go type in the Pokemon
cheetah hot dog well you might think
we'll that Yuki they don't know their if
the collie typhoon or Pokemon like they
do any nothing yes is it snowing right
now we might see a more no more our
lifestyle come on appearing in the field
and here we are
Terry taunting boys picking my fights
now of course you can you can access the
wild area from very early game but as we
see here there are some rather strong
Pokemon out there okay come on the Jovan
cut out why today the any other come on
the thing okay macoco thought they'd be
Takei performance against a little
disordered okuni you give up working on
this Emma cannot afford a very nice hard
and it for overtook Thor you get the
whole depending on where you go there'll
be some very high-level Pokemon do you
maybe can't take on probably run away
from this one
[Music]
[Music]
of course what are the other things that
we saw in one of the Nintendo directs
was that to kind of help you navigate
the wild area we saw the return of the
bicycle so the mice I killed them all me
that let's give it the [ __ ] or do you
think I'm a little bit Saviano you talk
about the family eating the language of
that so listening if I didn't shower far
more if all that is in the compact for
change and update from 14 I do work in
support of addictiveness they I think
they're a lot of fans looking forward to
the return of the bike and it definitely
helps you get around this wide area so
the typical would be a basketball
Yokosuka silk automatically Hamas I know
see Joanne is no mama no little moons
get all my solution for see John I
didn't date for your coordinator video
management is you hope in silico at the
Chianina
yeah really helps you get around the
wild area very quickly you can even hold
down the B button to kind of get a
little - move going so you get some
extra speed and as you saw if you just
kind of seamlessly transition to going
above like you know on the lake they're
kind of riding over the water so it
definitely helps you get around this is
definitely a bike I wish I had when I
was younger
let me get you around quickly and then
of course we also see that there's a you
know certain secrets out in the wild
there in for players to find no totally
not the khakhra
taking on a more timid state that is
shalini day
oh my initial to do the metallic CI you
know it's getting with the Vatican oxen
yeah every time you come back you'll
find like kind of hidden items in
different spots in the wild area if
there's a lot of fun to walk around and
discover them and of course activities
to enjoy like fishing motto pretty much
ah ok most people say oh this is pretty
more it the way they do uh they get in
this kiddo Matsuri more so much talk to
the dissonant yeah there's definitely a
lot to do in the wild area and as you
mentioned
fishing is one of them you don't know
Pokemon mediator and more stati you
don't know about Pokemon debt that is
they pushing out to there's a lot of
different ways to encounter the variety
of Pokemon in the area now one other
thing that we've noticed here on the
left side is that we're seeing some
icons pop up on the left side of this
I mean he died in a hole in each other
and here on the icon that didn't scare
me none - oh God
so this in a unknown and vital a ket
mamu toh soona weenie little nikon
Takara are in this key to move for they
are it why why to sing to each day Frank
I know so the seed ago did you do not to
assume also very honest to me back on
evaluation me Optimus so this is part of
the new kind of communication
functionality we're calling that through
this device called the why calm in the
games and you can actually have these
what we call on stamps appear to kind of
show what other players are up to it Mr
D top or a chocolate mousse on Hamas on
the so Adamo you also know it Coketown
type the icon pack Pony dilemmas so this
is actually a Masuda son playing right
next to us he's playing the Gloria
characters over yeah this stamp is
signifying that he wants to trade with
us macoco de Ito Cinco can toka I sent
oka all margin yogic a Qatari state not
a bomb oxidative a thermocouple a yoga
[ __ ] a photo Vatican so you can use
these dance and I've invite people to
battle trade or even try and get other
players to join you in a max rate okay
the audience he's playing Gloria right
now na na da na po prayaga Chico Mukti
chemosynthetic Susan discrete Omo
Sweta a free yoga the Alpha show them
Oliver's name so there's a lot of
different reasons that players will come
back to the wild area but you can kind
of encounter them other players that
were connected in the wild area in see
them in your game localization Dairy Bar
at Omaha Corazon de playa de san marcos
de sorry master see my internet position
Ostrava see guys you know play a la una
Y area they also say NASA photo Vatican
and this works either would be a local
wireless with other players that are
nearby playing at the same time you can
also connect to the internet to kind of
play with the other players from around
the world that's right it looks like now
terry has gotten to the town that we
were heading towards right but there's
some lights in the background the
red pillar evil lights could you guys
explain what these are - the more fixing
on a martini my torch action is Kevin hi
topa new Innova Chi Minh and ahsoka
so Davis any pokemon no sir stay the uh
no naka need me Johnny Kuryakin are
dyemax Pokemon ah you must so no not
power in it Giga right okay the details
so those are actually what are called
Pokemon dens and there's a red light
emitting from them when there is a
Dynomax pokemon inside so the red light
kind of represents the energy of the
Dynomax an unknown party notable
anecdote oxidative authority or change
the Cinco tequilas and what that means
for the player is that you can go there
and encounter that Dynomax pokemon in a
max raid battle well perhaps we should
show the max rate battle is like
something else academic bounty the
bathroom or his name did he yet to me
take the blame us hi
alright so as we're prepping up to
decide max rate battle mr. Mori mister
Masuda could you explain a little bit
more to the people watching at home
about what the Dynomax feature is the
dynamics in its victim also seek refuge
at the more devious cough
so let's now know cream adidas Nate
Omega sin cara de toda tu yo solo act
and SK the moves
no contact coop come on a pop through
cenote so toasty hydronic wanna die max
it is so Dynomax is actually a new way
to power up your Pokemon in these games
it replaces what we've seen previously
for example mega evolution and Z moves
Atos or die max de votantes que no NOS
kena topic mo akhirin de la foto de
víctimas de concave up a no boxcar amo
Tierra Verde no de cocora speaker and a
Lucario to Playland attracting you Tomas
and each player participating in the
battle can choose one Pokemon from
either their party or from the box so
it's important to choose one of your own
stronger Pokemon since you went before
you go into the matter a battle in
picking on there but you take okawa the
key no no they only ticket I sits in a
happy bit aside and you only get to
choose one and you can't change during
the battle so you've got to make sure
it's a good choice no you need a snack
or even tanto thinking a soui die Ginny
nothing their cooperation between the
players and also really determining the
walls is gonna be very important to
defeating the opponent mater bar I
thought Hypatia no silly my universe or
multiple came under to seem to not tick
quality still they think University
Roger was a polka mark I squatted a we
cut off support us with Universal ties
it up to me so I want to get into the
battle identifying maybe which of the
four Pokemon will have the best type
advantage to be the main attacker and
also like who can be the best kind of
support or the pokemon that will use
healing loose and support the team yes
I'm playing its Togekiss so for my my
first move I've used this report have
used reflect to try to protect all of us
a bit close no clown ok he saw it didn't
look good knowing no the crystal - they
stood on the team like mama no face
about hi thank you
what sort the mean that sweet of God
everyday put the cocoa get you got say
if I put the samosa get a big mess
that'll definitely help protect against
some of these powerful attacks
[Music]
I guess we should do roll call
I'm playing lead Akula over Luke oh so
I'm actually just got hit and as we can
see here steelix is doing multiple
attacks is that fair
so the Mahagonny oh god no don't okay
there it was all you know the drastic
Dundas kill the most likely score here
in this Oh No
Madhava to force it is my my module
curiosity but new people which is
stitched up in it
Samantha my dear my you don't stay on
you about it listen up the much yeah
when you're going up against the Dynomax
Pokemon sometimes they will take
multiple moves and so you really kind of
can't let your guard down
Digimon home with dad we need stuff
together so close take open up these
stuff so i'm i'm i'm actually the tom
character here playing arcanine is it
okay if I use Dynomax amok Suzanne under
Skidmore is Thor cutlet on Ethel 308
coaster my earth or the Canadians
initiative three of our Jumba need a
mocks Kenya my vickima see their puppets
you need they mock the beginning with it
very much I'm enjoying you still have
the ability to use Dynomax that actually
rotates between the players each turn
but you're keen you can only move
dynamaxx once throughout the entire
battle so it's important to kind of
identify what the exact right timing is
to be able to you know exploit the its
power so yeah obviously a lot of
strategy goes into these dynamics raid
battles
dynamics without Spoto its or small poke
on your big day very much
you know or no I understand you didn't
know you must and yeah you can see that
there are once you dynamaxx the pokemons
moves all turned into max moves which
are much more powerful and they also
have these added effects like you saw
the drought was just triggered based off
Arcanine attack yeah and they look
really cool too
a couple is now happy oku that's well
you know yeah definitely I think there's
it's very impressive and so we could see
steelix just put up a barrier around
nobody ma she did nothing day for Aviva
it sounded awesome our Senate report
Mamata a drinking soy he didn't care at
all I'm asking for the body on the ho so
it's named a body on on the scale more
it or not Sakina varriya dreamin about a
massacre it the mistake they nice to go
into her forehead cyclical so if I ever
we just must say but with the barrier
what happens is once the HP is reduced
it'll put up this kind of barrier that
you have to take down before I'll
actually start taking lots of damage
again the corner EEMA gauge [ __ ] it's a
mosquito damage your title voto nice to
know yes you got hit pretty much there
it saw hogyoku - p4k Monday mortify
Pokemon demo each EKG to hit taken all
day cannot achieve our Madonna Pokemon
them to forget you stick on a party all
across the table he just me but you can
see that there's a couple of different
like parts to the gauge and each time
you hit it with a damaging attack at
least one of those will be reduced so
even if your Pokemon isn't particularly
powerful in the attack Department it can
still reduce the gauge by just using a
damaging attack my max was about those
we gave it a spoke Americans
well yes as you can see my my togekiss
used dazzling clean which is not
particularly effective but was still
good enough to to break that barrier
down so Iman someone comes to Hiawatha
what's going on ski behind my gates or
demo get your head back to the forest
and the colicchio cougar now you've okay
Monday before it's about a suitable body
there's a good opportunity for even the
weaker Pokemon to you know participate
and really contribute to the fight and
Dynomax moves if you use it against it
it'll actually take down two gauges to
two slots of the gauge margays you'll
costs on got a lot more in Tulsa decade
oh yeah you guys have broken down the
barrier so now you just need to defeat
the Pokemon one thing that we haven't
talked about is that storm that's kind
of lurking around stealing promote you
personal all right tank Ohana and Ashoka
Maurya I'm old imma sue star okay more
nor enira Giga for sewage or they call a
lower it is okay that's really the kind
of the energy of the Dynomax phenomena
I'm just kind of brewing above their
head
but what's up with it plus I must name
looks like you're able they only gonna
be able to defeat this one that's too
much trouble
[Music]
Betty follow you're making with the
center of the country and we didn't have
a single Pokemon paint that was that was
actually pretty good
okay speaking royalties it's tonight uh
higher so now all of us have a chance to
actually catch this steelix so by
catching it can we add them to our party
for the short Easter it's come out a
chance to garden the filaments right
Sara Kimmel to Samos no bogeyman
Pacifica where to go I think it at the
village about ah so listening the kernel
map come on host outpost Alma get those
to the Chancellor Mary must it's come I
thought okay Mohammed emojis robotics
tally mark 42 re8 anymore in your
document schemata so yeah you can
actually every player who participates
in the battle are able to get a chance
to catch it but even if you don't catch
the Pokemon there's still a variety of
rewards for the players